[Music]
[Music]
hi folks sal khan here and all i have to
say is that algebra is perhaps the most
pure way of expressing human thought and
like everything dealing with human
thought it's incredibly creative
but you don't have to take my word for
it
we have some of my good friends to
better draw that link between algebra
and creativity
[Music]
it's all about solving problems it's not
about like maybe in previous years
you've done
a
multiplication table memorization it's
not like memorizing how to solve
problems it's learning the tools to how
of how to solve problems and then using
them um and building them up in creative
ways so it's kind of like it really does
remind me of art because if you are
doing like a painting or something you
have like specific tools about like
maybe paint brushes or different
techniques you can use um to create
something bigger um so i feel like
algebra is really all about combining
things that you already know how to do
um into something bigger so the word
algebra
comes from the arabic word algebra that
literally translates to
reunion of broken parts
this is breaking a part of mathematical
representations
and putting it back together in the form
of balanced equations is the essence of
algebra and the beautiful thing is that
this
balancing and solving of equations can
be done in many different ways which is
where creativity comes in
so if you're trying to communicate a
complex topic such as mathematics or a
mathematical problem to the general
public who might not be familiar with
the specifics behind that problem there
are many different ways to help you get
that concept across and one of the ways
that we do this in mathematicals is to
use videos and things that are visually
appealing to people so by using lots of
visual aids so bright colors and
cartoons and word prompts on your screen
you can engage and capture the audience
in different ways that you might not be
able to do if you're just speaking in
terms of equations and mathematics when
we're more creative about how we present
and how we talk about math it makes it
more relatable to people from a variety
of backgrounds and cultures and
experiences
when we are creative in how we explain
or how we relate
mathematical concepts we can use things
from sports entertainment or real world
to help really ground the principles
that we're learning and the theories
that we're learning to something
relatable so the more creative we can be
in explaining how math is related to the
world around us how it's related to
things that we are invested in the more
likely it is to resonate with the people
around us as soon as a problem is posed
our instinct is to find the solution but
remember often there's more than one
solution and usually there's more than
one path to it
one day my family was building this
fence around my chicken my chicken coop
because there were problems with
raccoons
and we wanted to make sure that like the
the perimeter of the fence was like
twice the the length of the uh
of the width and i remember thinking
this is exactly like my algebra class
like i'm actually doing things that are
um useful and actually like algebra
wasn't just something that you do on
paper it's something that like it was
actually like protecting the lives of my
chickens so i felt like that was a
moment for me where like
math is useful to the world and we're
solving real problems with it and it's
really powerful so i realized that i
first liked algebra and just math in
general my first year in college it was
a little bit of a late bloomer and
realizing the importance of math i was
taking an early statistics course for my
psychology degree
and i really began to understand how the
concepts that i were learning
um
could help me understand the world
around me better in a more concrete um
fluid and rich way and so being able to
make that connection from these things
that i'm learning in the classroom out
into the real world so i can understand
different phenomenon i can understand um
how various things in our culture work
and progress
really helped me and made me feel like i
had a deeper understanding for the
importance
of math and algebra and and from that
point i've really been in love
in order to get more creative i would
encourage young people to be not afraid
of making mistakes
it's okay to fail
while exploring a new trail of thought
know that usually there is more than one
solution to the problem math is as much
about posing problems as problem solving
and at that point creativity is noticing
where there is something worthwhile
investigating as a student in math i
think it's important to remember that
math isn't just like random symbols on
paper like math can mean something and
it's pretty powerful that you as a
student can build something that uses
math creativity in math isn't just about
being able to pluck numbers from the air
and like oh yes i know the solution it's
about
being able to use problems that help
with your daily life